that to me my god that's gonna chatter
chief another if you willing to hatch
when you said you want to chat it on
your roast beef they throw you out of
that cheddar cheese it that's what
people who are discussing the cot here
that's the people that you see in them
in 600-pound wine that's me
what's your recipe
uncle Joey here in full effect smoking
some [ __ ] refried had to say it's the
best weed I smoke in front I smoked the
bonus today and my wife said how come
you're so pale I was [ __ ] down and
smoking this [ __ ]
picked up presents on vinyl listen for
this masterpiece
nice family playing the [ __ ] game
school
the original sweet
you go [ __ ] blossom
Jimmy Page at its best for this this has
everything
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] that's why you get out
if you [ __ ] hillbilly fathers
some education
speaking of Education
[ __ ] hot it wasn't that bad today
people don't believe the news the forest
fires that's some [ __ ] awesome
that's Jenny even closed us everyday I
get calls from Jersey know is that fire
closed here yes around the forum this
one apology
microwave oven
trying to put this out back I'll be with
you [ __ ] on the second set I
got caught up oh [ __ ]
we're gonna pounce right there little
kangaroo two stars
there's some tremendous [ __ ] weed I
wish you guys could be his hardcore og
of perennials you should have seen the
buds of it they were like [ __ ] glass
I had to leave it in the car all day I
went to the weed store and then at the
[ __ ] tent and left them in the car
all day by the time I got this out of
six o'clock
with other Penguins move [ __ ]
that one right there that blue homework
don't that that Dale Dale Santana
yeah I got taken
are you [ __ ] care
the original hammer of the gods that's
the [ __ ] that comes out of the fight
with us not even noting it if you got
lost in the desert island with this pipe
you'd be good for a month
do a little birds [ __ ] dying here
where do you get that type as the time
man :
the other [ __ ] two mooks the English
[ __ ] at night [ __ ] them right here baby
is that the best weed in that light the
stars of death and a Jew it's like Jesus
came from the world same thing he
brought a jewel with him a star a duck
and a bowl of wheat you know why there's
no misunderstanding
you got a Jew of Halloween get some
water
Jews with a different level that's why I
was prepared to take them down
there's why they [ __ ] knew it I know
it
if you hang on the jewel upon Armenians
for a friend shoot yourself let's see we
got enemies
don't two three
warm
by
Oh
there you go
you're a seven star general
Mikey my man Thursday night Philly
one by one podcast that's my negro over
there in South Jersey holding it down
seven [ __ ] stars in what have you
done with your goddamn [ __ ] life I'm
I'm here I'm queer we get ready to start
the church we'll get ready and see the
devil
it's a Tuesday night and then hot no
more don't believe the hype
eat the [ __ ] tape all right you stop
with the smart way the other way wants
to dance with the Stars problem is
everyone's of their [ __ ] dancing they
usually if that was the one in your face
you understand me
it was a Tuesday night you got to go
deep [ __ ] if not why take why make
the move why even make the effort if you
know I only go [ __ ] deep well it's
Tuesday night I have one tomorrow go
[ __ ] yourself you don't [ __ ] think
about it
you throw them in your mouth like a
[ __ ] pistachio that's it
understanding while all the drunk in
there today's youth when it ain't so
funny
just [ __ ] launch it down I ate them
so fast and even tastier
have you guys checked it was [ __ ] one
of those days I didn't accomplish much
tomorrow I gotta face [ __ ] day then
Thursday it's off to Philadelphia
but five sold-out shows in my girl
Illinois and that's it [ __ ] I
can't you know I can't control myself
anymore because of you guys you guys are
the goods you know that you guys are the
[ __ ] goods waving
what's the matter late you believe he's
still showing stars over there
and you believe this [ __ ] he's still
over looks like coming to the chicks mom
there's no sink
nothing like smoking dope with my church
family kicking back
seven at once my records 22 one night by
mistake I don't know how to [ __ ] I ended
up here neither do you you know there's
so many things going on in your life
what I'll tell you what I am getting
sick of every time I took the TV on I
can't see Hillary Clinton over
I don't even turn the news on tonight
that's how bad is getting between Clint
Mallory the [ __ ] pulse the [ __ ]
Arab I can't take a number you know the
FBI went to his house twice then do that
with the [ __ ] guy with your friend
Lena I gotta sit there and watch this
every night and see these poor gay
people [ __ ] cry and it breaks my
[ __ ] heart you know get the [ __ ]
this guy's family and put them all in
[ __ ] jail I don't give a [ __ ] anymore
I gotta sit down every night to dinner
and get depressed with every day the
news drags in another [ __ ] dog you're
having a good day to you watch the
[ __ ] news
what happens to the gorillas nobody
gives a [ __ ] about the girl no more
[ __ ] you might as well shoot
yourself nobody gives a [ __ ] about you
know that's it we go from week to every
eight days which which mine sucks and
you notice that I know have to use a
young notice that every eighth day they
switch mine fox and thats it who gives a
[ __ ] anyway have I told you I'm stoned
that's what happens we need [ __ ] nine
stars smoke reefer from the dead
what time you got me
we'll see you [ __ ] in ten
minutes oh and she said do you wanna
don't you want cupcake okay